let's now talk about a couple of voter
suppression stories on Election Day I
listen very very carefully to this next
story
remember how Democratic challenger beta
O'Rourke is running against disgusting
depraved extremist Republican senator
Ted Cruz in Texas and I've been telling
you for months that you can vote today
to kick Ted Cruz out of the Senate well
the border patrol has decided to conduct
the crowd control exercise today
Election Day in El Paso Texas which
happens to be where bado or work lives
and enjoys some nice levels of support
and they are going to be conducting this
crowd control exercise right between a
Latino neighborhood and a nearby polling
place where many of those Latino voters
are going to be voting that's right vote
Border Patrol in what they call a mobile
field force demonstration on Election
Day in a neighborhood populated almost
exclusively by Latino voters and
adjacent to where many of them vote will
be in full force with this exercise the
ACLU is furious members of the
Congressional Hispanic Caucus are
disgusted and you can either attribute
bad faith or ignorant to this and either
way it's horrifying
either Border Patrol is doing this
deliberately to create an intimidating
and tense situation for people who are
realistically going to mostly support
bata or work or they are completely
ignorant about the idiocy of doing this
not only on Election Day but literally
between where a group of people that is
historically disadvantaged is going to
be trying to transit through in order to
get to their polling place and you can
say they got to file a lawsuit
screw them they only need to intimidate
enough people today to make a difference
and then file whatever lawsuits you want
it's going to be too late now in most
polls as we mentioned yeah it's head
Cruz is up around six points so it may
not really matter in the end but then
why do it at all if you experienced this
personally I would say let me know but
we're out of time you've got to let
local
law enforcement no maybe they'll listen
you've got to let the Election
Commission know you've got to let your
Secretary of State now because it is
same-day voter suppression that is going
on and I have more voter suppression to
talk to you about unfortunately one of
today's sponsors is Skillshare which is
an amazing online learning community
that offers thousands of high quality
classes on almost any topic the first
500 people will click the link under
this video we'll get to entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare they've got
classes on everything design video
editing photography business technology
cooking meditation even classes on how
to become a more productive person I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or will
help you with something in your everyday
life classes are taught by real people
who care about what they're teaching I
just took a really great class on more
advanced video editing techniques the
david pakman show is giving you two
months of free access to every class
they offer when you click the link under
this video I mean really just think
about everything that you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free that's hard to beat and
after that if you like it you can keep
having access to every class on
Skillshare for less than ten bucks a
month it's one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
because it's only available to the first
500 people who sign up